>> GREG: DID NEW YORK'S FAVORITE
SCHOOLLY WAG USE TO PERFORM IN
DRAG?
NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN GEORGE
SANTOS IS ACCUSED OF LYING ABOUT
ALMOST EVERYTHING EVER.
TO ME IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
INCLUDING HIS MOM BEING AT THE
WORLD TRADE CENTER ON 9/11,
TURNS OUT SHE WAS AT 7-ELEVEN ON
EARTH DAY.
NEXT, HE'LL SAY HE LOWERED
GASOLINE PRICES AND BEAT UP CORN
POP.
HE'S ALSO DENYING HE STOLE MONEY
FROM A DISABLED VETERAN TRYING
TO CARE FOR HIS SICK DOG.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT HE
REPORTEDLY COMMITTED THE MOST
EVIL OF EVILS, DRESSING IN DRAG.
A DRAG QUEEN AND FORMER FRIEND
OF SANTOS SAYS THEY MET MORE
THAN 15 YEARS AGO IN BRAZIL.
I KNEW WE HAD SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
BUT MUCH LIKE ME, GEORGE
COULDN'T HANDLE THE DRAG QUEEN
LIFESTYLE.
"HE DID NOT HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A PROFESSIONAL.
GEORGE DID NOT HAVE THE GLAMOUR
FOR THAT."
THAT'S A FRIEND, WHAT A CATTY
BITCH.
SANTOS TONIGHT PERFORMED AS A
DRAG QUEEN CALLING IT THE MOST
OBSESSION FROM THE MEDIA AND
CATEGORICALLY FALSE.
I GET HIS ANGER.
I MYSELF HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF
MAKING SOME EMBARRASSING
APPEARANCES IN SOME SEEDY
CIRCUMSTANCES VERY EARLY IN MY
CAREER BUT ENOUGH ABOUT FOX AND
FRIENDS.
SPEAKING OF, KAT --
>> THEY WERE SO NICE TO ME.
>> GREG: YOUR NEW BEST FRIENDS,
FOX AND FRIENDS.
THIS GUY, I HAVE TO DO A LITTLE
CAVEAT.
WE'VE REACHED OUT TO HAVE HIM ON
THE SHOW, HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WE WOULD TREAT HIM WITH SUCH
ADMIRATION FOR BEING SO WACKY.
SO CRAZY.
I JUST WANT TO GET INSIDE HIS
HEAD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
>> GREG: IT WOULD.
>> I HAVE HAD PEOPLE IN MY LIFE
THAT WERE PATHOLOGICAL LIARS AND
EVEN THEY STAY AWAY FROM 9/11
AND THE HOLOCAUST.
NOT THIS GUY.
BUT THEN HE'S LIKE, DRAG, I
WOULD NEVER -- WOULDN'T WANT,
YOU KNOW, ME THINKING THAT
YOU'RE NOT A GODLY MAN OF GOD,
LIKE YOU'RE A LIAR.
BUT I DON'T THINK -- HE WAS
OBVIOUSLY NOT, BECAUSE HIS
FRIEND WAS LIKE HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE GLAMOUR.
SO ALTHOUGH HE DID DRAG, HE WAS,
IN FACT, NOT A QUEEN.
>> GREG: OH.
PAUL -- YOU MUST BE, YOU'RE AN
AUTHOR AS WELL, YOU'VE WRITTEN A
NUMBER OF BOOKS.
YOU MUST BE FASCINATED BY THIS
CHARACTER.
>> HE IS FASCINATING.
>> HE'S GREAT.
THE MOST INTERESTING THING IN
CONGRESS, RIGHT?
I ACTUALLY HOPE HE HANGS AROUND
JUST SO WE CAN WATCH WHAT HE'S
GOING TO COME UP WITH NEXT.
>> GREG: EXACTLY.
>> HE FEELS LIKE THE SIMULATION.
THE ONLY THING I CAN THINK OF IS
THAT HE LEAKED THIS, HE'S GOING
TO GET ARRESTED AT SOME POINT,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE HE'S GOT SOME
FINANCIAL -- WHEN HE COMES OUT
WITH THE TRANSPHOBIA DEFENSE.
HE'S CHECKED ABOUT EVERY OTHER
BOX AND DONE JUST EVERYTHING
WRONG THAT HE CAN POSSIBLY DO
AND ULTIMATELY HE'LL FIND
HIMSELF LOOKING AT AN ARREST.
>> GOT TO GET HIM ON THE SHOW
FIRST.
I WANT HIM TO BE MY BEST FRIEND
BECAUSE I CAN TELL HIM ALL MY
SECRETS BECAUSE IF HE TELLS
OTHER PEOPLE THEY WON'T BELIEVE
HIM.
>> GREG: YES.
HE WOULD BE A TERRIBLE BEST
FRIEND BECAUSE HE WOULD ALWAYS
BE ASKING FOR MONEY AND THEN YOU
WOULD NEVER SEE IT.
RIGHT, TYRUS?
WE WERE WATCHING WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING BUT I'M
WONDERING WHAT WOULD DEMOCRATS
DO?
THEY NEVER QUESTION O'MAR AND
THE STUFF SHE'S BEEN UP TO.
BROTHER HUSBAND, HUSBAND
BROTHER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING,
TYRUS.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I FOUND IT OFFENSIVE,
HONESTLY.
THEY USED SOME HARSH LANGUAGE IN
THE STORY.
THEY CALLED HIM A DRAG DENIER.
SO NOW DENIER IS JUST ON
ANYTHING.
>> GREG: YES, IT IS.
>> YOU CAN PUT IT ON ANYTHING.
IF YOU DON'T WEAR A HAT, YOU'RE
A HAT DENIER.
IF I DON'T BEND DOWN TO TALK TO
YOU I'M A SHORT DENIER.
THEY JUST ARE GOING AT HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE LIES BECAUSE
HE LITERALLY HAS ONE OF THE MOST
INTERESTING LIVES OF ALL TIME.
HE'S BEEN EVERYWHERE.
HE'S LITERALLY -- HE'S DONE
EVERYTHING APPARENTLY.
AND, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHAT DID YOU SAY, HIS NAME IS
CADDIE BITCH?
PERFORMANCE NAME, JUST A
DESCRIPTION --
>> GREG: YES, YES.
>> I, FOR ONE, DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH GEORGE DRESSING
LIKE A WOMAN IN BRAZIL.
DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO TO HAVE A
GOOD TIME BUT WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
TALENT FOR LIP-SYNCING --
>> OH, NO --
>> ARE YOU OUT OF MY MIND?
LIP-SYNCING IS NOT A TALENT.
>> I WANT HIM TO TRY TO WALK
AROUND IN HEELS.
>> WHY WOULD I WANT -- THAT'S
NOT A SKILL.
WALKING HEELS -- YOU'VE GOT IT,
KID.
>> GREG: CAN WE GET A PICTURE OF
SANTOS?
I LOOK AT HIM AND I LOOK AT HIM
AND I GO, NOT THAT PICTURE.
A PICTURE OF HIM.
NEVER MIND.
I WAS GOING TO SAY, HE LOOKS
LIKE -- ANYWAY, THERE YOU GO.
ARE WE SURE THAT'S NOT REALLY
MARCO RUBIO?
>> WITH GLASSES?
>> GREG: WITH GLASSES.
LOOK, I FEEL LIKE YOU LOOK AT
OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT AND HIS
HISTORY OF SERIAL LYING,
EMBELLISHMENT, FABRICATION,
PLAGIARISM, I THINK GEORGE
SHOULD REALLY SHOOT FOR THE
STARS.
>> EXACTLY.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE A FUTURE IN
POLITICS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> IT'S SO FUNNY BECAUSE LIKE, I
MEAN, A LOT OF HIS -- OKAY,
SANTOS' LIES ARE ABSURD AND
COULD BE SO EASILY CHECKED.
LIKE HE WAS A VOLLEYBALL STAR --
>> THE PRESIDENT LIED ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF HIS OWN SON'S
DEATH.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S CHECKABLE AND REALLY
WEIRD.
>> GREG: YES.
EVERY DAY HE MAKES SOMETHING UP.
NONE OF THE THINGS THAT BIDEN
SAYS CAN EVEN BE FACT CHECKED.
>> GEORGE'S LIES ARE FUNNIER,
VOLLEYBALL STAR LIE -- HE WAS
STAR OF HIS VOLLEYBALL TEAM AT A
COLLEGE HE DIDN'T GO TO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING, MAYBE I SHOULD
POINT THIS OUT BEFORE WE GO, WE
NEVER HEARD ABOUT ANY OF THIS
UNTIL AFTER HE WON WHICH MEANT
THIS WAS ALL HELD BACK TO GET
HIM OUT SO THAT THE REPUBLICANS
--
>> HE WASN'T A THREAT.
THERE IS NO WAY THIS LYING GUY
IS GOING TO GET IN.
I THINK HE SAID IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF HE WINS, WE LET THIS
STUFF OUT, AND